did you know that the judge in the show
jury duty was a former trial attorney
who practiced for 40 years and is the
father of two successful Hollywood
actors and that the production crew had
to literally build tropical themed
hidden cameras so they'd blend in with
the surroundings at a Margaritaville
restaurant the wild yet incredible show
jury duty has masterfully Blended the
worlds of reality TV a game show and
scripted television into one perfect
mess
let's take a closer look behind the
scenes at how they pulled it off long
before they began filming certified
a-lister James Marsden was approached by
the guys who created the American office
Lee Eisenberg and Gene stepnitsky who
pitched him on an interesting concept
for a show it would be a fake jury duty
but they'd make it seem real it's a real
Courthouse but was abandoned we took it
over one celebrity and a bunch of improv
young improv actors at first he was
hesitant he didn't want to just be on a
prank show I said well I don't want to
do a prank show I don't want to make fun
of this guy who's in the dark but
eventually he realized he'd be able to
play a heightened and absurd version of
himself and at the same time do a little
ribbing of the stereotypical Hollywood
star it was a way for me to kind of send
up The Hollywood celebrity thing I was
like I've seen you somewhere I've been
in like so much stuff it's like
yeah yeah once the show got underway it
was an incredibly hard task for the cast
especially since they had to tiptoe the
line between playing fairly absurd
characters and keeping Ronald from
questioning the reality of the situation
I'd like to think that I pick up on
things and I'm pretty intuitive but they
all fooled me as actress Maria Russell
pointed out they didn't have to learn
any lines because the whole thing was
improvised but that didn't mean they
could Coast like at all they had to be
even more dialed in than in the scripted
show because the premise hinged on
Ronald not figuring it out we had to be
on our toes because Ronald turned left
we turned left James Marsden also talked
about how they had script elements told
to them each day so it was there were
scripts but there was no dialogue
scripted it was like okay this is the
moment where James goes and sits next to
Ronald there was no set dialogue and the
cast had to roll with anything that
happened but ultimately there was very
little room for error actor Ben Seward
talked about how he nearly blew his
cover one day with a careless exit from
the building I walked out of the door
that we were supposed to exit every day
and Ronald was there so I had to do that
thing where you just kind of back up and
close the door and in order to keep the
reality of the premise going the actors
were forced to literally sit for days on
end in a fake court case we really sat
for many many hours to make it seem real
there was also the intense emotional
weight that the cast and crew felt
knowing that they not only wanted to
make sure they weren't mocking or simply
pranking Ronald while also wanting to
keep the facade going Carrie O'Neal Who
not only played the security guard at
the entrance to the courthouse but also
wrote on the show talked about how
intense those feelings were I worked on
the show for over a year if Ronald
didn't feel like a hero at the end that
would break my heart now fans of the
show quickly became enamored of the
judge presiding over the fake case judge
Rosen sadly this trial will be my last
trial as an endearing yet fairly
no-nonsense judge he was one of the
essential glues that kept the production
together and his sense of authority was
seemingly genuine which no doubt helped
keep Ronald's confidence in the realness
of the trial but there's a lot more to
judge Rosen than you might think for
starters the man portraying him Alan
Barenholtz is no stranger to the legal
system I've been a practicing attorney
for over 40 years that experience as a
trial attorney means there wasn't much
in the fake courtroom that was gonna
throw him and yet he's not a judge in
real life he needed to find ways to
create a realistic judge character and
to do that he reached back into his many
memories from the courtroom I kind of
channeled the hundreds of Judges that
I've been in front of over the decades
that's not even the only wild thing
about Alan Barenholtz if that last name
sounds familiar it should he's the
father of both Ike and John Barenholtz
two super successful comedy actors and
writers Ike is probably the better known
of the two having star in movies like
blockers and the oath and shows like
history of the World Part 2 and The
Mindy Project so clearly the two
brothers come from a talented family
however they probably didn't realize
their father had talents in both the
legal and acting world and Barenholtz
wasn't the only person with legal
experience both of the primary attorneys
in the show Tricia lafosh and Evan
Williams are former lawyers turned
actors it was a large ensemble cast but
there was an even larger group of people
who auditioned for the part that
eventually went to Ronald Gladden he
joined 2500 other people who responded
to a Craigslist ad for a documentary but
it was pretty vague it basically just
said we're doing and never done before
behind the scenes look at what it's like
during the jury duty process the ad said
they wanted someone who had never served
on a jury before this was important to
the production team because it meant
that the person they cast wouldn't have
a great sense of what was supposed to
happen on a real trial so they'd be less
likely to be thrown at any bizarre
things that were thrown at the cast
there were a lot of potential people
they considered But ultimately they went
with Ronald because he was even in his
audition tape exhibiting signs of being
like a really good dude and of course
that was proven in the show itself as
Ronald basically acted like a saint
despite everybody acting cuckoo around
him a lot of the time and of course the
beauty of the deception was that Ronald
presumed it was indeed a documentary and
because they used that premise as
misdirection Ronald had no reason to
question all the cameras the interviews
being miked up and so on so while he
knew he was being filmed he didn't know
the extent of it nor the overall premise
it didn't even phase him when they had
to reshoot scenes because he assumed it
was for the documentary and at the same
time the show relied on a ton more
people than the small handful that
Ronald saw regularly he was usually
aware of a few camera operators as well
as a producer and like a sound person or
two but what Ronald didn't know was that
a production team of more than a hundred
people were working around the clock to
pull the whole thing off
that was a relatively easy task when
they were in a controlled environment
like the courthouse they had set up
things got a little more tricky when
they moved outside the courthouse and
there were times when they had the jury
venture out into the real world for
starters there were logistical issues
with filming in the hotel since it
wouldn't make a lot of sense for the
camera crew to be there for a
documentary so they relied on hidden
cameras placed throughout various rooms
there was even a level of deception when
it came to who was staying at the hotel
according to one of the actors Ross
Kimball they pretended that the hotel
was overbooked and that some of the jury
would be moved to another hotel but as
Kimball explained that was simply to
allow the actors who needed to go home
to their families each night a legit
excuse to not be in the hotel with
Ronald then the next morning they would
time their arrival to look like they'd
all just come from the same other Hotel
then there was the trip to
Margaritaville a local functioning
restaurant according to director Jake
sismanski the crew was tasked with not
only installing hidden cameras but all
also to make them blend in with the
unique Decor of the restaurant said Jake
quote we were hiding cameras in scuba
tank lighting fixtures and then we also
had to amplify the lighting in
Margaritaville so that we could see them
on our zoom lenses shooting through fake
mirrors now that's some impressive
camera work what's also impressive is
the lengths they went to make sure
Ronald was clueless unbeknownst to him
his girlfriend had been looped in on the
whole situation before he started
filming The Producers felt like she
could help lay the foundation of the
facade by mentioning certain things
beforehand that way in theory Ronald
wouldn't be so surprised by them for
example The Producers were apprehensive
about the fact that they were going to
take Ronald's phone from him so as the
trial was underway and it was heading
towards sequestering the jury Ronald let
his girlfriend know that was a
possibility she confirmed that it made
sense to her especially with the
presence of a major celebrity like James
Marsden she also quickly brought up the
likelihood that Ronald wouldn't be able
to have his phone on him that
reassurance from her helped smooth the
way way when that actually happened the
next day and according to the director
Jake susmanski that ended up changing
the way the scene went the actors had
all been preparing to make a fuss about
having to give up their phones but when
Ronald was suddenly like fine with it
thanks to the prep work his girlfriend
had done to help the show the cast
pulled back their reactions and acted
similar to him so I guess the big
takeaway here is that next time you
serve on a jury keep a real close eye
out for hidden cameras a production team
of 100 people and James Marston have any
thoughts about the behind the scenes
action of jury duty pop them in the
comments
[Music]